hey guys it is the 19th of November
today my name is just McDonald and
you're watching games but these i really
hope you didn't part this video cuz
seriously let's find out speaking of
which far cry 4 players reporting what
they thought with the bug accidentally
out of themselves for piracy the game
said outraged Pirates took to the
Internet to complain that the games
filled the view controls aren't present
it turns out they are if you have a
legit copy and we're eligible to get the
day one patch but as the game's creative
director Alex Hudgens and pointed out in
a tweet the feature were to be present
for those who grabbed the game via a
torrent awkward would you want to pick
up a ps4 for 50 bucks well it's
technically possible but it's certainly
shady probably even shady than the folks
in that last story certain individuals
have scammed walmart by taking advantage
of their price matching guarantee to
grab the ps4 at an unreasonably cheap
price of course price matching is legit
but these guys were creating fake amazon
selling accounts that were listing
sony's new gen console for massively
reduced prices and taking screenshots of
those pages to unsuspecting walmart
employees sneaky EA CFO Blake Jorgensen
has said that the Xbox one is catching
up to the ps4 in the scheme of worldwide
sales that fifty dollar Xbox one price
cut is apparently what's doing the trick
for Microsoft as well as those AC and
call of duty bundles Jorgensen is
predicting that after the holiday
shopping season more than 25 million
combined xbox one and ps4 systems will
be in the market it's suspected that the
current figure is above 15 million made
up of 10 million Pierce pores and more
than 5 million Xbox one's the EA exec
has said that more consoles on the
market is that to alleviate the
difficulty for publishers over the last
few years that was calls from people
purchasing less
in preparation for new gen ask your
question of the day let me know what you
think of that cheap ps4 loophole and if
you would do it you can head to gamespot
for more stories on things like the
titanfall deluxe edition and GTA 5
suspending its violence that is it for
me today I'll have more stuff for you
same time tomorrow but be sure to have
yourselves a good one until then